pensate se ti volevo dire che questo
spiegato che ci sta facendo la foto del
conto che distaccano chanel qualche
sollecitato la per quello scatto cito a
15.000 come 15 mi avevi detto 50.000
chiave 350 mila mia sto morendo di
farmacia faccio più di testa sentito un
po per chi ama palco edili che questa
sera non posso dare assolutamente alla
festa perché cerca via va bene ma
l'omaggio come prego no perché avevi
detto mary farne un quindi che con zero
che sei
no io non mangio non è l'altro mia
pagina wikipedia io sono in seta riana
cioè se non ci sono delle blatte dentro
per me è tutto schifo se ho fame mangia
cinici e poi denaro
senti mi puoi rifare con la posta dove
sembrate malnutrite più sottopeso ok
pensa ho fame grande grande
scusa stella per noi era gli sono messo
ho diversi ma [ __ ]
non è una scusa
non ringraziarmi
k
grazie ragazzo misterioso
ma tra il nome detto che al contrario
cioè le sopracciglia simmetria le tue
effettivamente sono molto simmetriche
pro piacente aspetto
io mi aspettavo qualcosa di più
romantico per sé magari un bacio no no
no no no salvare era per lasciarvi
indovina chi è arrivato un milione di
file tra pietro divertito io ti vedo un
po dimagrito dio grazie
pietro non sei grasso non mangi più
niente e preparato lo spuntino e dai
sacchetti con me
ok lo sanziona buoni a niente
no no non mi faccio avvenuto
no noi facciamo più
così se tu sei tu che ha smesso di
seguire da un milione di fuoco
veramente la lega non potevo sopportare
oltre moto mai visto come ti vesti
ciao ragazzi allora fatemi sapere nei
commenti qui sotto quale superpotere che
vorreste avere sempre piaciuto questo
video mettete un like condividetelo io
nel frattempo ringrazio enzo miccio per
la partecipazione sono molto grato
ringrazio per il supporto produttivo e
ci ha dato
ringrazio allo slingbox per la
realizzazione del video
ringrazio diana del bufalo e soprattutto
relazioni grazie a monza fa bene alla
prossima ciao ciao